former national security adviser and
retired general h.r mcmaster i would add
he's also a phd in military history from
unc chapel hill that could come in handy
this morning general uh your reaction to
the pictures and the news overnight and
also the big question what do you think
putin is after
well tony thanks i mean this really is
the end of our our holiday from history
and what you see is is russia uh and
putin in particular trying to restore
russia to national greatness and tony
this goes back to the collapse of the
soviet union in 1991 what putin saw as a
disaster and what putin has been driven
by since that time and since he took
over in 2000 in the year 2000
22 years ago he's been driven by a an
obsession with restoring russia to
national greatness and his plan to do
that is not to make russia great it's
really to drag everybody else down and
you're seeing you know the sustained
campaign uh against uh against you know
any any of the former territories of the
soviet union uh and the former warsaw
pact uh countries really uh designed to
restore russian influence in the in the
former territories of the soviet union
as part of that overall campaign to
restore russia to national greatness
if you're ukraine right now you are
outgunned you are outnumbered you are
led by a an individual who was an actor
and comedian just three years ago what
do you advise militarily
well they're they're fighting i mean the
ukraine's already fighting right they've
been fighting since 2014.
you know are there already been 14 000
deaths right in this in this in this
ongoing war is what we should remember
and ukraine has taken it obviously the
threat seriously since the invasion
began in 2014 the military is reformed
it's going to impose costs on russia and
this is really tony i think what we have
to watch is you know how are the russian
people going to respond now
to casualties and of course ukraine
deserves all of our support i'll tell
you tonight i wish we would see an
airlift that is kind of analogous to
the importance of history and analogies
to the 1973 airlift to israel when
israel was under duress and and of
course ukraine needs a lot of economic
support right we're talking a lot about
sanctions against russia but how about
economic support for ukraine which is
being strangled right now uh by the
russians with really a de facto blockade
going on in the in the south of ukraine
as well as these massed forces on its
borders
general it sounds like you're saying you
do not believe putin uh has an end game
with ukraine it may go beyond that so
the big question i think for americans
waking up this morning seeing these
pictures and thinking maybe this seems
very far away to that point of view you
say what
they say well these these threats that
develop abroad can only be dealt with at
an exorbitant cost once they reach our
shores that's why it's important to
impose costs on putin right now beyond
those that he factored into the
beginning of his decision-making he's
already threatened nuclear war tony and
so i i think what we have to see is is
this is this latest assault in a broader
context i mean just think about what
he's done since 2007. massive cyber
attacks on on estonia the invasion of
georgia in 2008 the constant you know
undermining of ukraine poisoning
presidential candidates for example
assassinations uh it's not going to be
the end of it what we've seen just in
recent days is that you're the
weaponization of migrants on the border
with uh and weeks uh with with poland uh
encouraging serbian separatists in the
balkans to reignite conflict there that
you know once you get to you know into
ukraine look at look at moldova you know
this is going to go on and on
until putin is met with strength he will
push as far as far as he can and i think
it's extremely important that we
maintain the unity we've seen so far and
i think we ought to we ought to applaud
the buy administration's effort to keep
the family together uh with the us uh uk
the eu european union and canada i think
responding together well and really
across the free world
general it is a new morning and a new
order in international politics and a
battle for global supremacy general
mcmaster thank you very much
thank you tony